[Music]
all the music stopped yeah hey you guys
I'm Katie Krauss and thanks for tuning
in to ET live I am so excited today
because Noah Cyrus is here and what a
week you have you have the new EP coming
out you're heading on tour I've gotten
the chance to listen all the way through
to good cry oh yeah yeah yeah we got the
link I got the link how are you feeling
right now I'm so stoked yeah I'm like
super happy I wrote like a whole album
already like a year ago you know and
then life kind of smacked me in the face
a little bit and and I rewrote a ton of
stuff and just made this EP on its own
like as a side thing and I realized that
like this EP and this type of music was
like the music I wanted to be making and
you know I don't know I just rolled with
it and good cry it's named after a song
that I wrote that's on the EP which is
one of my favorite songs that I wrote on
the EP so yeah I'm like beyond excited
it's like it's hard to explain because
like it's just been like two years of
like okay we're gonna put it out on out
here and then we don't put the album out
because I just wasn't ready yeah I
didn't I didn't know what I wanted to
talk about
I had nothing to talk about until until
I like lived right you know well what do
you want people to take away lyrically
and thematically from this album um like
what have you learned i I mean I I
learned a lot about relationships in the
past few years coming out of one that I
was in for two years that you know
there's obviously like ups and downs to
relationship and I also struggle with
heavy anxiety and depression and that's
pretty hard on the road to plus a
relationship and all of this stuff is
going on and that's what inspired the
record was every song was just from my
heart about this relationship and about
the way I was feeling and the and just I
didn't know how to communicate in any
other way but my music at this point
like some of these songs I would send to
my boy
at the time and would be like I don't
know how else to talk to you years a
song so I just I just like the song the
records really personal and obviously
like I've had some of these songs like
mad at you that I wrote like a year ago
and so it's just like so exciting that
they can all finally come out together
yeah
as you mentioned I mean there are songs
that really do dive into the whole
anxiety of it the heartbreak of it
anything that you were worried to put on
this record no because like it's all on
this like there's nothing like you know
I'm talking about myself like I'm just
talking about the way that I'm feeling
and what I'm going through but I know a
lot of people from communicating with my
fans on Instagram we DM a lot and we do
really yeah we Twitter DM will set like
I'll tweet like I'm gonna DM and like
whatever and then we'll talk and have
conversations or like just go through
Instagram DM something then I kind of
develop these friendships with them and
we start talking and checking up on each
other like and so I don't know I I just
want them to be able to I know that
they'll relate to this a lot because a
lot of my fans are young and going
through first loves or you know maybe
nothing compares to their first love or
anything of that sort that they can
listen to this album and they can turn
into this album and and find something
in this album
absolutely speaking of fans I want to
let you guys know to send in your
questions right now is totally ready to
take them and answer them let's go back
to some of these I feel like you've
lived such an incredible life but you're
only 18 years old how do you feel like
growing up in this spotlight has
influenced the music I mean do you feel
like you've lived more of a life than
most people I just think they're giving
me like it's like I've been in music
school my whole life yeah you would
think that I'm like really like techy
with music and you think that I could
like pull up on this iPad some beat real
quick man do you can't I feel like you
could no no no I can like play keyboard
with three fingers on this hand and one
finger on this hand but other than that
like I'm not the nails getting away for
guitar like yeah kind of I don't
but it definitely like harmonies are
something that I like picked up on so
early on in life that I fell in love
with harmonies my grandfather was in a
quartet so like I just like always loved
harmonies yeah and so they really I put
a lot of harmonies in my music because I
just loved them so much and like that
inspires me a lot and like just growing
up - all different genres but I think I
think the good cry EP was mostly
inspired by like Kanye Bonnie bear and
like Alex Turner oh wow yeah that's
awesome I was gonna ask if your family
influenced it or inspired a horse my dad
is like my biggest musical influence you
know so yeah I definitely he inspires me
a time yeah like I put I sent him my
records on really yeah and my mom I like
the first people I like sent record -
what do they think about this EP because
it's so personal were they shocked to
hear anything I think you know what I
think
my parents they they obviously knew I
was going through a tough time in kind
of every aspect not knowing where I was
going musically like just music wise
into like direction and and sound and
everything but also personally and
through a relationship and they were
just super supportive and they loved
every song on the record and my dad is
my biggest fan and so was my mom like
every song on the record they loved my
dad had mad at you down on guitar before
like I haven't even finished like the
production on the record like yeah he
was playing it and blasting it on his
speakers whenever it was just a tiny
little demo record yeah and he learned
it within like five minutes so he's
definitely my like biggest supporter and
like I get a ton of like inspiration
from him and his music of course there's
only six songs on this EP so how did you
choose which six made it and when did
you finalize that decision it was weird
it kind of just happened I like made mad
at you first actually mad at you I've
had like a year okay so like I didn't
even know I was making
you and I was making it and then let's
see it goes I think mad at you I don't
know that I'm giving out my track
listing but no the I I just did I didn't
know I was making me be but like I'm
losing my train of thought sorry what
no just how did you choose I'm sorry I'm
starting to name my songs and I haven't
given the tracklist yet I'm like realize
like I'm blowing my EP no good cry I
wrote like a couple months ago when I
was in Bali actually alright I'm like it
was the night of each he had passed away
actually and I like stayed up all night
like crying over that and I had gone to
a fight with my absent everything was
just kind of like held me down and I was
really really far away I'm rambling off
sorry guys I was really really far away
from home and I just wanted to like go
to my mom's house and like cry and just
like just like it just it was a really
heavy night you know everybody in
America had just gotten the news that of
each she had passed and I was going to
sleep and so like it was really just
insane and it was a really long night
and I stayed up till like 6 a.m. crying
and ended up writing good cry and I
don't know it all happened in different
ways but it kind of like each song was
made and then I'd be like oh you should
put that on and albums yeah and then we
just like they're basically all the most
recent songs that I've written
did you know EVG no but it was a dream
of mine to work with him yeah so one of
my favorite songs like ever written is
addicted to you and so it was like a
dream of mine to work with the beachy
yeah and I loved him so much and he's a
legend well he's so young it was so
young and then you have Mac Miller now
and it's just it's been a hard time for
music xyn and little peep they have a
record together and they just dropped
that which makes them really really
happy and it was beautiful to hear their
voices again I like heard X talking on
the record this morning whenever I heard
it for the first time and it was like so
refreshing to hear him
yeah like rest in peace Silla Legends
bro Mac Miller P X a V
she everybody yes infuse all the legends
yeah I do well we have some fan
questions coming out that we're gonna
take really fast Maria says is Noah
focusing on music or is she gonna start
a new path with acting Oh kind of like
that clue Noah's focusing on music but
I'm also definitely like open to acting
I would love to see you in a sitcom a
sitcom yeah that'd be awesome
okay like a Modern Family sitcom yeah
cuz you're funny like you have the you
have the humor chops down
there's we're gonna get two more of
these fan questions in just a second but
there's a song on the record that I'm
obsessed with and I don't want to give
away the name can i yeah sure I don't
care okay it's called Topanga and it's
so raw it's out like yeah it's out to
eight hours it's fine go ahead and blow
it girl this song though is gonna
transform your career I think like it's
so real so honest walk me through the
writing process of that song okay well
you guys haven't heard Topanga but I
look at the script there's a screen here
you guys I'm looking at the screen is if
you can see me through the screen I'm
sorry I topanga's a one-take song it was
done in one take yeah so Topanga it's a
voice mom off my friend ill see small
huh we were sitting on this I have a
green bench in my backyard and I had
gotten I don't know it's really you'll
hear it in the record I got some news
from a friend about you know someone I
used to be really close with in it you
know it was just like oh wow they're
moving on good for them but it just hurt
a little bit and so I was like please
come over I need to write a song can you
bring your guitar and so she just
started playing the beginning of Topanga
and I just wrote the verses with her
like talking about like everything in
Topanga like the soap reference is about
sofas Bevan what so preferences about
Trader Joe's peppermint so no yeah so
they're all very specific Topanga is a
huge part of that point in my life and
so that was my most recent song I made
it the voice memo and I
sorry we're putting a voice memo on the
album I sent it to the ANR and I said I
said let's put this on the album my NR
is amazing her name is Jenny Anders and
I love her so much she's like one of my
best friends but I texted her and I was
just like yo this has to go out as one
take so it's funny because there's a lot
of crickets in Topanga because I
recorded it at nighttime and her phone
my phone she was on the ground and then
we were sitting on a bench like this and
she has a guitar so we like to say it's
no Cyrus featuring the crickets because
they're louder than me yeah like rest in
peace to the headphone users because
like it's gonna be really loud cuz the
crickets are like it didn't bother me
blaring I felt like it made it really
real I had a friend go I feel like you
should take the crickets out and I go
well I can't
he has their real life crickets and that
was one take and what night was that was
that recent yeah that was about two
weeks ago
oh my so you really added a song that
you did two weeks ago to the CP deck
yeah on Friday
yeah and then sadness I don't we just
finished the production on sadness like
Friday last Friday
speaking of sadness with this sweatshirt
it says sadness yes this is my new Pizza
slime collab it comes out today I'm
really excited so go check it out we
have a ton of really fun outfits and
stuff I've never talked about my own
like collab I don't even know how to do
that I love it well I need some also
some good cry merch and I feel like this
goes in line with that oh yes it
definitely goes with the good prime
merch yeah I'll definitely send you this
and the good yeah I need both my dad's
are huge Oh again my dad's a huge
inspiration I my dad I recreated my
dad's merch from the 90s as my own merch
I'll show you after wait that's all so
that's what's going on the good pride
tour and then also you guys want the
check Pizza slime when they officially
drop this but I have a fun billy-ray
t-shirt in store for pizza slime and
it's personally my favorite of the
collection yeah so you guys definitely
have to go check it out because it's my
favorite thing in the whole world I love
it
I do want to talk about mad at you
it more are we getting a music video
anytime soon I'm filming it tomorrow oh
you are okay yeah I go from here to a
fitting and then I go to Santa Clarita
oh I gotta film I know my interview my
music video tomorrow and then Friday I
leave on tour and Saturday is my first
so when do you sleep
when I have time and you when you make
time when yeah yeah yeah like last night
I went to bed at like 3:00 and woke up
at like 6:00 okay I do have to ask you
we saw you in August with your then
boyfriend lil van at the VMAs you guys
looked so in love fast forward to a few
weeks later what happened and how are
you doing I'm fine yeah totally fine you
seem fine yeah I think it's just
something that we both will move on from
and it's all love it's all good you know
I'm confused that's all I'm sayin that's
cool I mean what why are you confused I
did it's just it was a shock for
everybody I think I didn't know what was
gonna happen
this isn't honestly there's no point in
drama really dry because tour EP piece
of slime there's no like I'm just like I
just got to focus on me right now and I
don't really need to have a boyfriend
right now anyways and I realized that
when everything blew up in my face like
Noah just take a time to take the time
to work on yourself and make yourself
happy yeah and you don't need a man to
make you happy
that's for all of you girls out there
and you do not need a guy to make you
happy that's for sure
yeah I love that it's not for your dad's
daddies are the best mothers and
brothers yeah so brothers brothers will
get angry at ex-boyfriends and is that
what that attack know they are
protective be careful with brothers and
boyfriends no thanks yeah is it hard to
go through stuff like that so publicly I
have my whole life's moon public's know
is
doesn't it's fine my life has been
public my whole life so I was like born
on a Billy Ray Cyrus concert it feels
like yeah I see yeah I mean it's kind of
crazy let's talk about tour for a second
how do you choose the setlist
how did I choose and sellers yeah I just
wanna ah I go by flow okay I don't know
so like I like to like keep it flowing
in the beginning and then I get to like
the chill part in the middle then I like
to come home with like the meat and
potatoes yeah the box are we gonna hear
any covers of anything totally I don't
want to give away my cover okay so like
I'm really excited for my cover family
covers well you know somebody did guess
that I was gonna cover a bluegrass state
of mind my dad's song yeah tattooed and
I'm not and then I was like that's a
good idea but we're a week away from
tour I am NOT learning a whole news yeah
yeah that's pretty hard well I actually
my fans are choosing my setlist for me
I always saw that you were instagramming
yeah like send me your ideas yeah so
we'll see their ideas I might have to
make a couple little changes yeah but I
I think their ideas will be great how do
you handle being on the road because I
imagine that it gets kind of lonely do
you bring anything from home with you my
you face if I could don't you go on the
road with you or not he's going for the
first week okay and then honestly I'm
really tight with my band and everybody
like around me in the bus and everything
and actually like my best friend in the
whole world is opening that for me her
name is Maddy noise she's incredible go
check her out so she will be on the bus
together so that's all I would need
really but I FaceTime hella like yeah
like every day do you really yeah just
like family members friends yeah my mom
all day like my mom it's so funny you
she'll be in the office like where she
works and does her Productions stuff
yeah she's she's so cute your mom is
adorable I was it her but she will
answer for me though no stop calling me
you are driving me not I don't believe
that no I swear to you I bet my I
thought my pop this is another room
laughing right now because it's one kind
of a century she gets so annoyed with me
calling her yeah because it is every
five seconds she's like between you and
Miley I can't I can't have me time yeah
it's like no a Miley Miley no miley on
FaceTime yeah what do you guys FaceTime
your mom about the most like what do you
need everything just like it'll just be
mom
the gardener told me this is this is a
mess mom I was just in Walmart and you
don't even believe like with the lady in
Aisle 6 dad and my mom was like why are
you calling me then out of nowhere of
course my mom will go crying on and
she's like okay what happened and then
we're all good and like it's very up and
down yeah we know two of us I think I
mean I she also has five kids so like
she has that going all day she knows
she's like yeah let's take a few more of
these fan questions someone just says no
way you're the most beautiful woman in
the world
Thank You Alyssa says if a singer wants
to start singing like like you where
should they start oh you could start so
many places because there's so many like
play places you can put your music yeah
I can put it on YouTube you could put it
on Instagram they know how bents the TV
like Spotify iTunes SoundCloud
everything there's so many things you
can do to get recognized but what I
would do is just like start writing and
like figure out the stuff you enjoy and
what like relates to you and just like
get comfortable with yourself writing
and make songs and like eventually like
put it up on YouTube like you don't need
a record label to get recognition like
there's so many artists to prove that
like all of these amazing rappers like
alright yeah and they're just everybody
you can be independent and make it is
what I'm saying so do what you want to
do cuz you can do it this album you said
that you wrote obviously the majority of
it it's very personal it's a little bit
autobiographical would you say totally
what's your favorite lyric on there do
you have one oh my god on the whole
yeah I'm gonna have to like think of
every it would probably be from Topanga
it's strange how time could turn sweet
love to indifference mmm that's my
favorite it's not with my favorite line
so real yeah because it just you when
you're in a relationship for a very long
time living with somebody you so
suddenly out of nowhere just drift mmm
it's sometimes yes and you're a
difference is really start to clash and
it's hard when you're around somebody
all the time and you become like angry
at this person and you fight and it's
like becomes this like toxic environment
for you and who you're with and like in
my case it was something where neither
of us wanted to not be together mm-hmm
and so it was just not the right time
and that's all that line is saying is
it's just strange how time can like turn
us into different people so suddenly and
we used to agree on everything and we
used to be like best friends but now out
of nowhere like it's just like things
are different and it's crazy how you
gonna go from like living with somebody
to being complete strangers yeah this is
the ex before lols and though right yeah
this is somebody before I just I want
people to get yeah I was in a
relationship for two years and so you
were living with somebody when you were
16 no I no no okay no when I this it's a
touchy subject let's move on okay we're
gonna move on from that lots of general
love and I love yous coming through
right now Erica says how many tattoos do
you have and what do they mean to you
like 15 tattoos for real 50/50 well a
lot of them on your hands but they're
all here so I can't really show you but
there
all of my arms and stuff like I've got
these right here is that the deathly
hallows this is a Legend of Zelda I look
like that's a B for breeze and my
brother yeah
and that's for Alex Turner that's four
stars out of five he has a song that art
doing Keys have a song called four out
of five it's their like latest Eve
Constantine that's a horse that passed
away when I was 15
it's the rock and roll emoji yeah it
looks to me it looks like a turkey
before you cook it like on Christmas I
like really don't like it but it's cool
yeah it's cool
ah it's fine this is stand still that's
me and my dad's motto man yeah there's
so many yeah there's a lot like I
explained them all but ride or cry is my
favorite I love that one is that the
newest one these two are the newest yeah
oh and well I got a lip tattoo like
inside but I'm not even gonna show
because it doesn't it's not there
anymore
cuz it goes away yeah I've heard that
but that's why hey now this looks like
weird like dark things yeah no I want to
see it but I won't do it right now okay
and then our last band question I'm
gonna ask is from Matt Chell did you
ever think of going to college or was
being a singer the only option ooh
singing was the only option
no well not option I had many options I
could I can we can do whatever we want
to do any of us but singing was what I
wanted to do and I was not a school
person so college is not for me would
you ever go back to school no no no I'll
take I was I saw my mom I was gonna take
some like online stuff just on like
subjects that I liked but like I don't
have time for that maybe after the tour
I have like this hundred page book that
I've gotten like five pages in in like
two months like it's like I've like
literally I'm just writing
um [ __ ] all the time now yeah it's like
I get so tired what is and then I want
to play a little game with you but what
is the biggest lesson that you've
learned about relationships and love and
yourself because that is so much of what
this album is I mean you learn a lot but
like I think sorry I'm reading I'm sorry
I'm reading these did you everything
going on did we answer all of that yeah
we answered all of them okay can you
learn more fan questions I feel like we
only answered like to keep sending them
guys yeah I like paying question sorry
what was the question um just what have
you learned most about yourself and
about love and as you've drawn the past
couple years about myself yeah I think
I've learned to accept myself for who I
am a little more and not just out of the
love stuff because we talk about it so
frequently that like I just I I just
learned a lot about like finding myself
and finding out you know what I need to
do to make myself happy and not make
everybody else around me happy and that
was something I would do before is like
I came absolutely last and and I like
was working all the time I'm like really
really tired and and I just needed some
time to like figure my head out yeah and
then and then I learned a lot like about
social media used to really get to me
and so I learned a lot about not letting
that get to me anymore and stuff like
that so you read the comments yeah how
is it working with extant osteon yeah
it's mainly he's a legend they dropped a
new song of his with little Pete today
it's beautiful you should go listen to
it I love eggs he's amazing again I'm so
blessed to have that record oh they also
asked and mustard DJ mustard mustard on
a bee ho
[Music]
is opening right around the beat oh he's
awesome too
he's sick we just like ordered mashed
potatoes and satin studio and ate mashed
potatoes I think that's what we had
that's awesome yeah I want to hang in
the studio any mashed potatoes yeah we
got like some food all right we're gonna
play a little game with you it is called
Noah's good cry in honor of the EP
coming out this Friday all questions
about crying basically okay all right
the movie that you can't watch without
crying
PS I love you oh so good dude they added
it to Netflix the other day and I was
like come on like don't do this to me
all the fields my okay my roommate came
in yeah in the last scene where she has
him read the note to her and I literally
had to stop him because I was like hold
on I got to hear this yeah my prized
play I only watched it to watch that
scene like I skip to that scene if you
played it right now I'd cry like really
like I just started sobbing and he goes
well I'm gonna leave you to do this and
then I'll come back in ten minutes
because he knew that I definitely needed
that so when I need a good cry put on PS
I love you so if I'm feeling sad and
like I need to cry but I can't get the
tears out and I'll watch something like
that and then I'll get the tears out and
it makes me feel better something nice
and sappy yeah
um the person in your life who makes you
cry of laughter oh my gosh my friend
Andrew Wells he's an amazing producer
he's super awesome but he makes me cry a
laughter to like he is that he is
probably the most hilarious person in
the whole world and my dad yeah but my
friend Andrew Wells is the funniest
person in the whole world the last time
that you broke down and just let it all
out
sobbed yesterday yesterday like twice
this week I do that all the time yeah
well you're going through I'm going
through it right now there's like
there's just a lot of like you know
sometimes life gives you things once and
then like you have like a break and then
sometimes it's just like BAM and it's
like wow like life slow down for a
second but it's about doing going on
everything's good it's all good vibes
you know yeah I get it there's been like
while I'm home like la is a hectic place
and so it's gonna be good to get out of
LA yeah I'm glad that you're looking
forward to Tori oh yeah this song that
makes you cry mm glass in the park Alex
Turner hmm yeah the best way to bounce
back from a cry a good a good laugh okay
you've gotta like you know every time I
finish crying you know when someone will
make you laugh and cry for long and
that's a really good feeling it's like
the little laugh and then you're like
sniffily and you're like laughing and
you're kind of still print I do that all
right maybe that's just me no cuz I mean
maybe I only one that laughs that like
if somebody makes me laugh I'll like
start crying again
you're being so nice but no that's a
good feeling that you're right yeah
makes you realize like maybe it's not as
bad as you think
yeah yeah I know okay last one is your
favorite comfort food when you're when
you're feeling like you're gonna cry
honey cruel errs what are those they're
the bomb
they're so good they're from Tim Hortons
in Canada okay and but you can get them
at Dunkin Donuts as French cruller but
they're my favorite doughnuts
I can eat like ten of them and not like
it's like the glazed doughnuts if I ate
ten of those like I feel like I'm just
gonna throw yeah there's something about
these Hank rulers that I can put down
like I love honey brewing yeah I need to
try these there are my favorite so
Canada you can get him though these are
Dunkin Donuts here as a French cruller
okay put in Tim Hortons sock okay
they're called honey cruller honey
coolers I'm into that um thank you so
much for being here for this with us why
don't you tell them where they can get
the EP on Friday for tickets yes
EP is on Friday it's called good cry and
then also the good cry tour starts
Saturday my first show is in Fort
Lauderdale so get your tickets and I
can't wait to see you guys lots of love
thank
you guys for watching make sure that you
subscribe like this video and we'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you